welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode we'll be revisiting
Jordan peels us love it or hate it the
film is incredibly dense so we thought
we'd put together a list of everything
you missed first time that you notice on
a second watch this video contains
things I noticed as well as Twitter user
Eve wing who's just created an entire
thread that Jordan Peele even retweeted
so make sure you head over to their
profile to check out the full list after
this video from here on out its full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the movie yet and don't want to know
anything about it then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I'm definition and let's get
into the full list of everything you
missed from your first watch of us okay
so the first big thing that you pick up
from the opener of the film is the
thriller t-shirt that young Adelaide is
given at the carnival in the infamous
music video for that song Michael
Jackson not only transforms into a
werewolf but also a zombie which
confirms the notion of duality when
discussing the choice of the thriller T
your daniil the film's director said the
duality with which I experienced him in
that time was both as the guy that
presented his outward positivity but
also the thriller video which scared me
to death in addition to this Michael
Jackson also made the song man in the
mirror which is a motif that plays
heavily into the house of mirrors scene
Zora the daughter of the Wilsons is
training to be an athlete and a father
Gabe suggests that she should run in the
sand under sub optimal conditions to get
better at running this is why she's no
match for hombre who easily chases her
down due to the fact that she's been
trained to run underground and is
therefore faster and stronger
the name hombre means the dark moon
shadow that causes an eclipse which ties
heavily into the shadows which is what
the tethered refer to themselves as in
addition to this Zora also wears a shirt
with the white rabbit on before changing
it in the film to one that says though
which means rabbit in Vietnamese those
who've seen the matrix will be familiar
with the fact that white rabbits are
often references to Alice in Wonderland
which this film has tons of nods towards
in Alice in Wonderland Alice follows a
white rabbit into the
world that is a weird uncanny version of
her own Adelaide's childhood toy is also
a white rabbit and when she sees it in
the house the repressed memories from
her childhood come back when entering
the subterranean tunnel the first thing
Adelaide sees is a single white rabbit
if that doesn't affirm the ties there's
also a sequel to Alice in Wonderland
which is called through the looking
glass in which Alice climbs through a
mirror to discover a distorted version
of her own universe another item of
clothing worn by Zora is a badge with a
raven on it the Raven is a story by
Edgar Allan Poe in which a man is
haunted at night by an otherworldly
visitor that won't leave him alone
similar to the way that the tethered
invade the Wilsons family home in the
film red even begins their first
encounter almost like a story by stating
once upon a time there was a girl and
the girl had a shadow which further
cements the literary notion of the film
early on in the film we see a scene in
which you're living spider emerges from
underneath a fake one much in the same
way that the real Adelaide emerges to
start their quest for revenge against
the fake one when entering the house of
mirrors the real Adelaide whistles the
itsy-bitsy spider
and this thematically shows that she is
coming back to take over at the beach we
meet the Wilsons family friends who have
twin daughters the gained this continues
the duality mirroring and showcases that
there are doubles for everyone it's also
at the beach scene that we see a red
frisbee covering up a blue circle on a
towel this symbolizes red coming to take
over when entering the house red moves
at weird right angles and later when she
fights her movements are very deliberate
and square this is because she's Easter
living underground and having to move
through tunnels and their corners she
also knows that the key is hidden under
a rock which is a dead giveaway that
she's lived on the surface before
throughout the fight red tends to stick
to the shadows whilst Adelaide fights
the light once again showcasing their
duality when Adelaide escapes from the
house she starts running around
handcuffed to herself
however she manages to break this which
of course shows the separation from red
at the beach we learn that katie has had
some form of plastic surgery and her
shadow Dahlia tries to copy this by
cutting herself with scissors
the scissors to represent the opposing
sides of the characters personalities
the design of the scissors looks like
heads facing in opposite directions they
can either be brought closer together or
move further apart but if one side of
the scissors moves the opposite side
boobs with it again this follows the
mirror motif and in the film the
tethered copied the moves of their
counterparts on the surface and finally
the title itself possesses a double
meaning in the film Adelaide states we
are Americans and with the title being
us
this of course can be changed to stand
for United States the movie hammers home
the idea that the US needs to look at
itself with the Hands Across America
finale and it's definitely a double
meaning to add to the pile and that's
everything you missed on the first watch
obviously with the film this dense
there's gonna be a ton of things that I
miss too so if you noticed anything that
wasn't in the list make sure you leave
it in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and share
it with your friends and make sure you
check out my fan theory on why Jason
isn't the real Jason which would be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]